in the brave new world of steam early
access there's only one host daring
intrepid and resourceful enough to steer
you past the pitfalls of paying for
games that are still in development and
until we find that person I'm your host
Chris waters in today's episode we've
got dispatches from our far flung
correspondents around the globe about
games that will broaden your horizons
first up is Starbound Maxwell McGee
spent a lot of time delving deep
underground to bring you this report
because either he doesn't know where
stars are or I've grossly misunderstood
the very foundation of this game
starbound is a game of exploration
item-crafting monster slaying and
occasional intergalactic piracy in fact
it's far too expansive to pigeonhole
into one single category in the
beginning a short series of introductory
missions guide you through the basics
but the training wheels soon fall off
and you're left to engage the wild as
you deem fit will you construct great
buildings or forge mighty weapons maybe
you'll dig a really deep hole and die in
it actually you'll almost certainly end
up dying in some deep dark pit such as
the cold uncaring nature of Starbound
however the harshness of this world
while cruel at times also makes your
victories feel that much sweeter and as
you progress further in the game and
your understanding of how its many
different parts and systems all fit
together it's a delight to see the list
of things you can do as a player grow
and expand in unexpected ways this is
especially true when you save up enough
fuel to travel to a distant planet and
Rob the locals blind hey such as the
cold uncaring nature of Starbound when I
asked Danny O'Dwyer what the game
secrets of rate akan was he told me it
was about birds flying about and birds
hopefully he's flesh those ideas out of
it or else this next segment is going to
be really short
secrets of rado con is a game from
broken rules the Austrian masterminds
behind one of my favorite steam releases
of all time and yet it moves and much
like the papercraft platformer it's not
an easy game to sum up essentially this
is the spiritual successor to their
second game chasing aurora which came
out on the wii u in 2012 in it you play
as a solitary bird swooping through the
landscapes diving into caves and soaring
into the air through wind currents this
is a game about unraveling the secrets
of the landscape you solve puzzles
collect trinkets from civilizations past
and interact with the various fauna that
inhabits this wonderfully angular world
you can defend yourself with plants or
sacrifice smaller birds to your prey to
distract them or just chuck bunnies
around in terms of early access it
appears to be on the home stretch the
studio has been working on it for about
three years and the version I played is
stable and looks and sounds fantastic
you get access to the entire main camp a
and except for the grand finale the
reveal of the secret itself it also
comes at a pretty full-on editor which
you can create your own levels that will
be shareable via Steam Workshop in true
broken rules form this game is available
on PC Mac and Linux the nine dollars 99
cents with twenty five percent off this
first week this is about as close to a
full release as you're likely to get on
steam early access so if you're in the
mood to play something clever and
incredibly unique pick up secrets of red
oak on today our dreams can take us too
fantastical places frighten us with
lurking horrors or take us back in time
to high school where we're late for
class and don't know our schedule and
forgot the code or a locker and have no
shoes Jess McDonald drifted into dream
for this next segment where fortunately
things turned out to be a bit more
interesting than your average recurring
anxiety dream
from the outset dream feels a bit like
gone home a daunting house dotted with
dark hallways serves as the foundation
for the game world but is in no way the
extent of it dream is a first-person
exploration game which takes place
outside of reality for the most part or
at least outside of the corporeal waking
world you traverse places created
through the lucid dreaming of your
protagonist Howard Phillips which extend
from great white rooms punctuated by
menacing black cubes to sprawling
deserts it all means something as dreams
often do you just need to find out what
so far the gameplay appears to hop
between puzzling exploration and long
narrative segments which illustrate some
of the plot there are moments a very
effective horror tangled into the lucid
dreaming experience which include a
puzzle of escaping a pursuing shadow
monster in a maze while trying to
activate an elevator or seeming as if
you've awoken only to read a message
scrawled in blood on your bathroom wall
the currently in alpha game isn't
without its bugs or occasional T diems
where it's unclear what you're supposed
to achieve particularly when sequences
can repeat themselves that aside the
overall intrigue of the story and the
beautifully detailed game world keep
dream feeling like it's brimming with
potential on top of that the oculus rift
support at launch really does just cinch
the deal and with that I'll leave you to
go off on virtual adventures of your own
but before you go let us know in the
comments below which of the games so far
has piqued your interest the most thanks
for watching and we'll see you tomorrow